俺の人生にパーミングポイント
もうすることはないでしょうか俺は今まで数々のヘリコプターを飛ばしてきた俺の家
ん
2回ぐらいですね数々ではないです理解だ事項ヘリを飛ばしたんですけども何度でも
こうちょっとうなっていかないかんきて終わってるんですよでも今日はね今日は質問時
違うぜ
今日はもうねぇ俺を心配するという範囲でくるなちょっと
たちもお付けしてます
[音楽]
デカちゃい安と2ということでまぁ見てもらって分かると思うんですけども
バカでかいです何かね115cm のビッグサイズこれがでタブー
お店で一番打ちたくねこれが他の最強です家は後の再調査委がヘリコプターをまあ言え
ず飛ばそうと思いますまあぜ劇でいってもんなんだよ
いやそういうわけじゃないと思うけど持って飼い方がいいじゃん
美味しそうですねねええええ
1巻2杯こんな感じで取り付け方法を変えておりますね
なる
なるほど
すげー
全然分かりませんちゃんといろいろ説明してやる多分なんとかなる正位置盤
本体のテールシャッドの雪コードの単車赤白それぞれの色に合わせる前です
[音楽]
なんてきそうだわーよろしくああああっ
だれがぁああ
ああああああこれぞああ
おおおおおお
わー legends わああああ
第二レター本体の底シャッターせずコードターン数をそれぞれ分けて説明します
なるほどなるほどなんとなくわかったのはフレーズですこれをくっつけなきゃいけない
とわかった固定ぼ
そいつらを使うんですこれか
[音楽]
なんかエロいねこれでいいなあこの知らないぞ固定されているはずです
あーで時代2件なんせ頬をどうやってやるの
ぐりぐり無理あきたきたきたきたもうありますとりあえずまたよ
1回動く方は確かめよう
まだ飛ばさないですよ動くかどうかだけを確認したのでこれで果たして動くかどうか
っていう
動いてくれれば一番いいんですけどきた
ああああああ
うんっ
[拍手]
良い音がカーッ
えっ
イケルはおけるぺぺー済みなつっていけるから
ぺちゃんとをつけますとベルはちゃんと中電します
もし吉田羊もしかしてだけど
今回はじめいけるんじゃないの
よろしく請戸ボスというするけどもしかしてだけど持ってるだよ
今回はじめ中に取れるんじゃないなぁおおぉ
もしかしだけど方もしかしたけどお母さんに怒ら
てるんじゃない道よしぜひ音声
[音楽]
吉住か妙なや尿叶うかみたいなバディ
注いでいこうさあ皆さん大変長らくお待たせいたしました
良いよねあの超貴重だけど飛ばすという来たってバギーなんでなんか待って全部性根で
の
everyone ok 美容系左 ok だね ok という
[音楽]
ana
me
bejean
tan
一心で2本持ってくれたああ
[拍手]
家であるもんじゃね